luke and nate here with the outdoor boys
youtube channel and we're in seward
alaska and any minute now a boat's going
to take us
off into the wilderness where we are
going to explore and camp at an
abandoned
military
there you base
[Music]
that's leaving us behind we gotta walk
home
think we can do it check it out guys
we're all alone only way me and nate are
getting back is with our own two feet
but check it out there's this old dock
here
that's remnants of the supply dock for
the military base that we're gonna go
explore
and over here in the woods
you can see these concrete footings
going off into the woods they're part of
an auxiliary building
this military base was built here
because of the japanese invasion of
alaska a lot of people don't realize
this
but during world war ii the japanese
attacked
and invaded and occupied parts of alaska
for 16 months and there was some
incredibly bloody battles fought here in
alaska
and because of that the military built
lots of
bases to protect our coastline and our
harbors including here in resurrection
bay
and so up on the top of the mountain up
there
is one of those world war ii military
bases
but it's been abandoned now and we get
to climb inside
and explore all the bunkers and all the
fun stuff and we're really jazzed
but first we need to find a campsite
look at this
it's a kelp bowl here pick it up it's
like a balloon
see on the floor
yep that's what makes kelp float all
right
got a little fireplace here
nice level spot over here
well we have the tent set up how about
we go explore a military base
yeah all right let's do it
if you want to know more about the
japanese invasion of alaska an excellent
book to read
is the thousand mile war absolutely
fascinating fascinating history this
trail is pretty nice it used to be an
old jeep trail for getting
supplies from the docks up to the top of
the battery
what a view even on a cloudy day it's
beautiful
check it out this is this is devil's
club
it's got all of these spines on it oh
it's kind of like the stinging nettle of
the north but has some medicinal uses
this is a berry this is a red version oh
that's nice and bright
you want that
there's white ones and red ones
check out this bear den look in here
look at that
[Music]
yep that's black bear poop
see all the seeds in it about anywhere
you go in alaska is bear country
so you better bring something to protect
yourself and
i like to use the bear maze and it works
definitely works um but it's got limited
range probably about 20 feet
the upside is you don't really have to
aim
this part of alaska rains all of the
time if you stand still
too long in seward you'll end up covered
in moss too
hey nathan nathan do you see the
military base
no it's hidden it's right here can you
see it
you see it up here i'll give you a hint
it's up there
can you see it
look at this this down here goes to the
military bases underground
ah this
used to be up here but a bear probably
chewed it up
and ripped it off yeah this is a vent
it's the secret base is underneath us
what is this thing
i can hear it's like a flu i can hear
something moving down there
can you go inside of the base we gotta
go find the secret entrance
let's go keep looking in the woods keep
looking in the woods for more
entrances come here
all right buddy you ready
all right let's go
this is probably just one bunker there's
more
should we go look for some more yeah
in case look how hidden this
is there's no way you could shoot this
from the water
and good luck spotting it from a plane i
mean this this would be really hard to
bomb or shoot with artillery
anything did you spot something yeah
show me show me what you found
you got your flashlight
it's like a tent like a metal tent look
at this i think there's another one over
here
i think there might be one over there
look at this door that door is like
solid steel look at that
yeah you had the vents up there
wonder what they put in here it's been
about three quarters of a mile since we
found our first building
and they're just all over the place
overgrown with moss and
off in the woods we probably walked past
half a dozen that we didn't even notice
hey nathan look at this seaway out there
the ocean
and the far bank that's seward
that's where we're hiking to tomorrow oh
that's really far away oh we got a lot
of hiking to do
oh look at this energy oh
and there's something back here take it
out
this goes to a light that's where you
screw a light bulb in
and there's the electrical wires and
there's
another light bulb outlet
oh and look here's another vent
that's tipped over there's another vent
and there's some roofing material
my guess this was a normal wood building
and not a bunker
that's why the the lights are right here
because this used to be inside
there's a couple six inch by six inch
posts right there so some building used
to be there in the woods
yeah see that this is another building
look at that here's some pipes go down
this is part of the building too we're
standing on part of the building
look that's pavement that's four inches
of reinforced asphalt
you're standing on top of some sort of
bunker or road or something
there's probably 20 30 buildings up here
you could spend
hours exploring this hey that looks
serious
you ready
all right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is so cool look how thick these
doors are
oh it's so cold in here look at all the
droplets from water leaking out of the
ceiling
so much water coming through the ceiling
oh look at that there's like a secret a
secret tunnel that goes outside
oh that looks like old water that's
dripped in from the ceiling
[Music]
here let's go around this is dead end
[Music]
thank you i think this is something we
open this oh this is totally rusted
watch out there's a trapdoor
[Music]
how deep does that go
does this go all the way down
holy there's another room over here
look at that there's like some sort of
light switch
oh it's all rusted
that's the floor tiles and uh
the ceiling's probably asbestos or
something
oh you can see the floors the floors
were like a checkerboard they had red
black red black
i wonder if this was like a mess hall or
something
look at that
there's a little air duct in there
there's like secret compartments under
the floor
yeah i wonder if that's for like
electrical work or for water to go out
oh look at all those pipes in there see
look at that
see that it's a normal apartment
whoa this is so big
there's like look at this there's doors
look at all these doors
[Music]
yeah let's go check it out oh look look
there's
there's stalactites growing there's like
a cave look at that
[Music]
i don't know if this is where people
lived who slept or
where offices were oh look at this
[Music]
whoa it's a whole bunch of prank pieces
oh i guess i can't fit in there man this
hallway is
long look at all these rooms
one
this is one of the few that i can
squeeze through
oh look over here we made it out
oh look at this nate look at this
we found it this is where the guns used
to be
look at this this is where the giant
six-inch artillery guns were
and look over here resurrection bay
yeah anybody who wanted to sail in and
attack seward
had to sail past this point and they
could shoot at anything
in the bay wow look at that view no
wonder they wanted this
on the other side of resurrection bay i
think right over there
there was another military installation
as well so they had
guns on both sides just heaven help
anyone who tried to sail up this bay
let's see yeah down here
wait for me all right
that was cool was that totally worth the
hike
yeah oh look at this
let's see what's in here oh look at this
it's a machine gun nest
see look at this they got these plates
that are bulletproof like this is like
one
inch steel there's these rails and so
they could go and move it along this
and the plates are on hinges
so that even if the bullet hits it it'll
flap and drop the bullet instead of
penetrating
oh man that is smart that's so cool
you want to go up this trail oh look at
that is that neat
man imagine trying to shoot at somebody
inside there that would be really hard
what is this what'd you find
yeah there's like oh that's like a
little bunker for hot fighting
but it's blocked off with concrete
that's probably a little fighting pill
box
oh there's a trap door of some sort
nope just took some random path through
the woods and
another chunk of concrete and who knows
what's at the end of this path
is this cool or what nathan i'm really
having fun
so in case you're wondering the name of
this fort is fort gilvery
and it's on kane's head near seward
alaska there in the woods i can see just
the corner of some concrete bunker but
there's a
big patch of devil's club we'd have to
go through to get to it so i think i'm
good
yeah i think this building was just
wasn't a bunker it was just like a
normal building
holy mackerel it's just like the forest
has swallowed it up
look at this these trees are just
growing straight through where the
building used to be
there's something over here too
pilings right there the wood pilings
there's the wood beams
right there and then this pipe
that looks like a sewer pipe to me it's
so weird you're just in the middle of
these woods right here
and then you look down and there's a
manhole
well nathan shall we go back to camp
yeah yeah we got some good food waiting
for us back at the camp
i'm looking forward to that
i love it when the hike back to camp is
downhill downhill yeah
in a roundabout way the japanese
invasion of alaska is responsible for my
family ending up in alaska
when my grandparents were living in
bellingham washington during world war
ii they befriended a couple that were
refugees
from alaska they'd fled the invasion and
after the war was over those friends
convinced my grandparents to go back up
to alaska with them
and that's how my family ended up in
alaska this was before
it was a state
oh look look at this it's a jellyfish
look at this it's a big jellyfish see
him he's huge we're back at camp and now
we need to get some firewood gathered up
so i've emptied my backpack so i got
plenty of room
to put wood in it
when i was kid we used to call this moss
witch's hair
and we'd use this as a fire starter so
i'm gonna grab a bunch of this stuff
and i'm gonna see if i can knock this
tree down and use that
then
good save dad yeah that's right to get
you nice
all right buddy come on you ready
his dad had some mad skills thumbs up
for that
uh
got that
on the menu today is a prime well
seasoned
one and a half pound steak with green
beans and warm bread
however nathan wants a cup of noodle
that's his jam
that's all right
here's dry green beans they're good
just bite off the ends
that good well nathan it is past your
bedtime and we have to get up early
should we get going to bed yeah go ahead
and hop on inside buddy
we got nathan to bed got the food put
away now
i'm gonna make nathan a hiking stick for
tomorrow
he's got a long hike
there we go perfect walking stick well
today was a lot of fun but tomorrow is
going to be a lot of work and adventure
um i'm going to be hiking five miles
through trail i've never been on before
and three of that will be across
a low tide beach zone and if we don't
get those three miles covered fast
enough
we will be stranded uh and we'll have to
wait 12 hours
for the next low tide to be able to
finish our hike so
no stopping no turning back we're gonna
go to bed get a short night's sleep
and i'll see you guys in the morning all
right nathan you up
yeah you angry at me still a little bit
because i woke up in the night
well it's 4 40 in the morning our packs
are on our back and our camp is broken
down
things were said that can't be unsaid
but i think our relationship will mend
the sunrise is about 45 minutes and the
tide is way out there
and it'll continue to fall for another
hour 15 minutes another is
a squidward
well there we go this is the beach two
and a half miles that way
till we get off it now it looks pretty
easy right
but there's two choke points on this
trail where we have to sneak
around the toe of some cliffs and if the
tide comes up
we can't make it and we're trapped on
the beach
and in order to come here on foot you've
got to have a low tide
that's three feet or less now this week
the only tie that fits the bill is the
am
tide which is really early and so
nobody's been hiking in so by taking the
water taxi
and then hiking out at the 5 50 a.m
tied we have just been the only ones
here we
absolutely had this entire state park to
ourselves
and it's been awesome you look like
you're doing a lot better buddy
that's well i wonder and now i'm going
to eat you
what'd you find oh yeah look at that
this is the second one
[Music]
look at this this is beautiful
oh look at the size of that jellyfish
that thing's huge you know nathan when i
was a boy
i went clam digging and there were so
many jellyfish on the beach
that they were as deep as your knees
tired has turned
and is now officially coming in
hey look at all those muscles i can see
a bunch of pink salmon jumping in the
cove over there makes me really wish i
had
my fishing rod
that's a starfish oh look here's another
one
yeah he's alive
what a gorgeous place man this is just
amazing there's a sea otter right there
see him i must really be a virginia boy
now because i brought
biscuits and gravy with us and we're
gonna stop and have a biscuits and gravy
break
there you go cold biscuit and gravy
sandwich right there
oh darn that still tastes real good
we got another half a mile or so of
beach and then
a couple miles through forested stream
this is my walking stick walk walk
[Music]
walk
[Music]
ugh
[Music]
that's a chump salmon right there that's
a chum that's
chum there's a whole bunch of salmon in
[Music]
here
nathan took a spill and hit his head on
a rock oh
all the crazy places we've been hiking
any trips on a gravel road
[Music]
that's miller's landing where we started
this whole adventure
nathan was that an adventure yeah i hope
you guys enjoyed this video
as much as we enjoyed filming this video
if you guys want to see more information
about this hike
and miller's landing and how to do this
i'll put information in the video
description below and if you want to see
a video of our entire six week adventure
here in alaska
i'll put a link to that in the video
description as well
thanks for watching guys and don't
forget to click subscribe
we put out new videos every saturday
morning if you like this video don't
forget to check out the outdoor boys
youtube channel where we have hundreds
of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
saturday morning
and hit that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching